todo lo que hemos hablado hasta ahora
implicó reconocer y etiquetar o captar
elementos son moléculas extrañas que se
encuentran afuera de las células afuera
t
las
lunas
hemos visto células como la célula ve
una célula ve tiene anticuerpos o
inmunoglobulinas de membrana quizá una
de éstas podría reconocer alguna
molécula extraña afuera de la célula y
por supuesto esta parte de aquí como
sabemos todas tienen una porción
variable justo aquí esto es específico a
esta molécula extraña luego ésta será
captada y después partes de ellas serán
unidas a un complejo cnh 2 déjame hacer
eso en un color diferente entonces se
unirán con un complejo
m h 2 y luego esto irá a la superficie
esto irá a la membrana de la célula para
presentarse ese es un complejo c m h 2 y
tiene un pequeño pedazo de la molécula
extraña de aquí afuera llamamos a este
pequeño pedazo de molécula extraña
antígeno esta es una célula presentadora
de antígeno y hemos visto especialmente
como esta es una célula ve que después
una célula de auxiliar que también tiene
una pequeña porción que corresponde a
este antígeno específico esta de aquí es
una célula t auxiliar justo aquí
esta es una célula de auxiliar
cuando la reconoce entonces empezará a
dividirse en linfocitos t de memoria y
en linfocitos t efectores y los
linfocitos de efectores esencialmente
activan las alarmas y empiezan a
acelerar la replicación de las células b
o creo que podrías decir que es la
activación de la célula ve y la teoría
es que esto es como un proceso de
apretón de manos doble pero nuevamente
esto es lo que está ocurriendo afuera de
las células cuando encontramos moléculas
extrañas afuera de las células las
captamos y luego las presentamos en
complejos e mc2 en complejos se m h 2
ahora probablemente estás pensando bueno
esa es la parte de afuera de las células
a este c m2 están estas células de
auxiliares pero también nos hemos
referido a células citotóxicas que es lo
que ellas hacen y ya que hay smh 2
probablemente hay complejo c m h 1 que
es lo que hace el complejo smh 1 y
podemos reconocer a moléculas extrañas
afuera de las células pero esas
moléculas extrañas
algunas veces aparecen adentro de las
células como responde nuestro sistema
inmune a eso y como puedes imaginar
todas esas preguntas se responderán en
el resto de este vídeo pensemos en lo
que sucede cuando empiezan a aparecer
moléculas extrañas
pero de la célula por ejemplo podrían no
ser incluso por un virus o por algún
tipo de bacteria podría ser que la misma
célula lo haga digamos que esto de aquí
es una célula cancerosa ha tenido
algunas mutaciones y ha empezado a
multiplicarse como loca
esta es una célula cancerosa
y ya que la célula cancerosa ha mutado
va a producir unas proteínas extrañas
estas células cancerosas empezarán a
producir proteínas inusuales cada célula
con un núcleo en tu cuerpo y eso incluye
casi a cualquier célula exceptuando a
los glóbulos rojos cada célula tiene
complejos m h1 y el objetivo de los
complejos cm1 es unirse a moléculas
extrañas que se produzcan dentro de la
célula moléculas extrañas que se
producen adentro de la célula y luego
presentarlas a la membrana incluso una
célula cancerosa con un mal
funcionamiento debería de estar haciendo
esto este compuesto cm1 se une a estas
proteínas extrañas que son producidas
por las mutaciones adentro del núcleo y
luego puede presentarlas
y entonces podrías imaginar como debería
de ser la respuesta inmune adecuada
estas células cancerosas deberán ser
asesinadas y de hecho déjame etiquetar a
esto adecuadamente esto era el cnh 2
estás presentando un antígeno que fue
encontrado inicialmente afuera de la
célula capturado y luego expulsado y
luego el cce m
h1 se une a moléculas extrañas adentro
de la célula y luego las presenta afuera
ahora esta de aquí debería ser asesinada
y como te podrías imaginar que es lo que
la matará bueno ahí es cuando aparecen
las células citotóxicas la célula te
citotóxica tendrá eso de allí es un
receptor
tendrá una porción variable específica
para este tipo de antígeno y entonces se
enlazará allí y ya que hace eso dirá
caray hay bastantes moléculas extrañas
aquí estas proteínas extrañas que se
están produciendo estas células y todas
las que se le parezca deben de ser
asesinadas así que la célula te
citotóxica empezará a replicarse como
otros tipos de células inmunes y se
replicará en células de de memoria
sólo en el caso de que éstos se
presenten nuevamente diez años después y
también en células de efectoras estas
son las
y memoria
también las efectoras
y también células
tórax
células de efectoras citotóxicas y como
sabemos la versión effect ahora es de
hecho la que hace algo la que empieza a
afectar las cosas y que es lo que va a
afectar de hecho va a empezar a unir dos
cosas que presenten el mismo antígeno
como parte de su m r arriba de su
complejo se m h uno este carácter de
aquí
está presentando ese mismo antígeno
presenta ese mismo antígeno en este
complejo cm1 y recuerda las porciones
variables necesitan emparejarse digamos
que esta es una célula t citotóxica
effects ahora esta es la célula t
citotóxica efector a su receptor su
porción variable es la que es compatible
con este antígeno que está siendo
presentado justo aquí déjame solo volver
a etiquetar esto este es el complejo ce
m h
esta es una célula de citotóxica effect
ahora pondré la cee aquí por citotóxica
y lo que hace es esencialmente adherirse
a la célula que tiene que morir y lo
hace
no solo tiene este receptor
interactuando con el complejo cm1 sino
que de hecho tiene una serie completa de
proteínas y no estoy dibujando esto a
escala realmente debería de ser mucho
más pequeña o relativa a la escala de la
célula esencialmente se adhiere entre
las dos y no iré a los detalles pero
esencialmente forma lo que podemos
llamar sinapsis inmunitaria que es donde
están interactuando la una con la otra y
entonces cuando identifica esto dice de
acuerdo tengo que matar a esta célula o
esencialmente tengo que hacer que esta
célula se mate a sí misma
empieza a liberar todas estas moléculas
puede liberar moléculas como las
perforina las que esencialmente causarán
la formación de huecos hoyos en la
membrana de la célula que necesita morir
y podrá liberar gran cimas que pueden
entrar y esencialmente hacer que esta
cosa se mate a sí misma el objetivo de
este vídeo es conocer de lo que creo que
no hemos hablado aún ya mencionamos lo
que sucede cuando identificas moléculas
extrañas afuera de la célula y luego de
cómo las puedes llevar adentro y
posteriormente presentarlas y luego
utilizar eso para después activar la
respuesta inmune ahora hablamos de cómo
identificar moléculas extrañas dentro de
las células
estas son presentadas por los complejos
cm1 y luego las células citotóxicas las
reconocen y obligan a las células a
matarse a ellas mismas y éstas podrían
no sólo ser células cancerosas podría
aplicarse también las células que ya han
sido infectadas por un virus por ejemplo
una célula como
está
este es su núcleo ya ha sido infectada
por algún virus el virus ha secuestrado
el mecanismo de replicación de la célula
para replicarse a sí mismo y entonces la
respuesta inmune apropiada es decir hey
soy una máquina que hace virus debería
de matarme a mí misma
algunos de los antígenos producidos
adentro de los virus se unirán a
complejos cm1 pedazos de virus se van a
adherir a complejos cm1 y luego serán
presentados en la superficie déjame
hacerlo de esta manera se presentaran en
la superficie para que todo este proceso
pueda suceder nuevamente